NUMBER TWO HE'S BACK IN THE
LINEUP.
NASHVILLE CAME DEMELO?
I CAN'T WITH A
LOT O THE
NET.
TOLVANEN TIPS IT AND HE FOLLOWS
THAT PLAY TOWARDS PLAY A HIGH S?
IN FACT HE'S GOING TO CALL THE
REFEREE SHOULDERS.
HE'S COMING DOWN, IT'S ABOVE NOW
AND WING AND TRENIN
AND MORRISSEY WAS ABLE HAVE BEEL
>> THAT'S A GOOD LOOK THERE TO E
HIGH SLOT RIGHT HERE.
THIS TIME TO REATTACK.
AND IT'S THAT CONNECTIVITY AGAIS
WELL.
AND TWOOFF.
GOT IT DOWN LOW WITH THAT TOP
LINE
DOWN.
IT WAS PARTIALLY BLOCKED BY ON
THAT ONE TO GO DOWN FIVE ON
THREASTE SOME TIME
ALONG THE BOARDS AS HE STRIPS TP
SHOT.
>> STILL TIME FORF THE GAME.
WE ARE SITTING THERE ON THE
BENCH OH NO, WHAT DO
YOU WANTFORE THEY COULD GET OFFS
INTERCEPTED BY SEASON.
>> IT IS NOT AS MUCH HEADLINES
THE PERIOD
MAKING IT AEMELO.
ALLOWING THEM TO PUSH IN.
HEAROS.
ALL OF A SUDDEN HE WAS WIDE THUY
20, 2022.
>> A GOOD KEEP IN.
UP THING HE
PUCK LOOSEND LOOK AT THIS WITHE
CONNOR, PUTTING HIS BODY ON THE
LINE.